so then part two of the implosion of
Donald Trump's lawyer Rudy Rudy Giuliani
is after putting out that unintelligible
statement I told you about earlier where
it sort of seemed like he was
backtracking on some of the things he
said about the hundred and thirty
thousand dollar stormy Daniels hush
money repayment by Trump to Michael
Cohen Giuliani appeared on ABC Sunday
morning talk show this week and he
dismissed his own statements as mere
rumors and then contradicted himself
multiple times right I'm gonna play this
for you and I want to prepare you
because of the hyper normalization right
are becoming accustomed to realities
that would have been inconceivable
before the Trump era the interview I'm
about to play might not immediately
strike you as the unhinged drivel that
it is but we have to contextualize it
I'm about to play a clip for you from an
interview where the attorney charged
with speaking to Robert Muller on behalf
of the President of the United States is
being interviewed this is not some
lawyer that your landlord hires to evict
the tenant right this is the former
mayor of New York City hired by the
President of the United States to
represent him in something that could
conceivably expose alleged criminal
activity by a sitting president and this
is how his lawyer represents him on
national television take a look but on
the other day you also told BuzzFeed
though that at some point after the 2016
election Michael Cohen had complained to
some people that he hadn't been paid by
Donald Trump and that so then you said
Cohen met with Trump and told him and
Giuliani said that will cover your
expenses they work at this $35,000 a
month retainer after that so so the
President did know about this after the
campaign I can't say that I mean I at
some point yes but it could have been
recently it could have been a while back
those are the facts but we're still
working on and that you know maybe in a
little bit of dispute this is more rumor
than it is anything else well that's
what you said you said that to BuzzFeed
but Rudy Giuliani says these are mere
rumors and George Stephanopoulos points
out well you're the source like you're
I'm quoting you here if you're
dismissing the stormy Daniels hush money
repayment and installments from Trump to
Cohen as a rumor that's a rumor you
started so how does Rudy Giuliani
respond this is his answer to that but
here's the I mean that's that's
one of the possibilities and one of the
rumors the reality is you stated it is
fact well maybe I did but I was right
now I'm at the point where I'm learning
and I can only I can't prove that I can
just say it's rumor I could prove it's
rumor but I can't prove it's fact
yeah it's rumor that's right he can
prove it's a rumor of a fact but he's
not yet ready to prove the factual
nature of the rumor of the fact which by
the way all came from him didn't Trump
hire this guy like wouldn't the first
thing he would go to trump and say is
well give me the facts so that I don't
end up spreading rumors on television
right like the is Trump admitting to
pain cocaine Cohen back or not and if
you can't get the information from the
guy who's just hired you maybe this is
not a guy you should be working for
right and here it continues and it only
gets worse you but you've said is it it
isn't you said as a matter of fact on
Hannity and BuzzFeed you talk to the
well I don't know how do you separate
fact and opinion that's its opinion I'll
say this is my opinion and when I state
a fact also you said the president
worked out a retainer agreement with
Michael Cohen after the election order
to repay him on a settlement to stormy
Daniels the second part the second part
of it the last part of it the the
retainer agreement was to repay expenses
which turns out to have included this
one to the woman the asan Saturday Night
Live last night trying to make more
money and now our NDA with her seems to
be irrelevant because she wants to break
it up because she wants to make a lot
more money than hundred and thirty
thousand I never thought a hundred and
thirty thousand I know this sounds funny
to people there at home I never thought
a hundred thirty thousand was a real
payment it's a nuisance payment when I
settled this for when it was real or a
real possibility it's a couple million
dollars not not a hundred thirty
thousand let's get back to the couple
million dollars thing because that's
stunning language has no meaning anymore
right even though he literally went on
hannity and said this is what took place
we should have realized that what he
meant was these are rumors which i'm
creating about what took place it's not
actually what happened it's my opinion
as just a random guy about one
possibility of what might have happened
it's Orwellian doublespeak at its finest
and then at the end he throws that thing
in where he says listen 130,000 dollars
isn't even really big enough to be a
payoff for something serious anyway
this would have been if I was involved
in actually settling this it would have
been a couple million dollars that's not
a great thing to say that's exactly what
stormy Daniels was saying during the 60
Minutes interview which is she only
agreed to accept a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars because she was being
intimidated but she actually would have
wanted and potentially could have gotten
more based on the damage that she could
have done to Donald Trump before the
campaign it is a comedy of boneheaded
stupidity and then of course the final
question is well why hasn't Trump been
honest about all this but you don't go
away 430-thousand of a Meritor dude call
it a settlement payment the President
did make these payments to Michael Cohen
over the course of 2017 according to you
then why did on April 5th why did the
president deny any knowledge of the
payments when in fact well I don't know
I don't know when the president learned
about it he could have learned about it
after or not connected the whole thing
at at that time it was crazy
Trump was just so confused he had no
idea what was going on
this is gaslighting folks plain and
simple and it might be catalyzed by
incompetence and the people surrounding
Trump but the impact is gaslighting as I
have been discussing and this confuses
the average person apparently Trump was
also confused because Trump lied because
Rudy said Trump made the payment but
here's Rudy saying that the word of the
payment was just a rumor that he started
it's not actually something that he's
investigated it makes no sense and it's
makes such little sense that even Neil
Cavuto as I told you about earlier on
the program had to go out there and say
mr. president you're really not making
any sense here the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad